what was her biggest takeaway certainly
Vladimir Putin made a lot of assertions
he gave himself credit for helping
Russia avoid a deep crisis what was your
biggest takeaway what did you learn well
I mean I think someone observed to me
and he clearly wants to talk to the
United States he said you know that
they're surviving the sanctions that's
one thing he said he said that they
he talked about Ukraine a bit and talked
about Ukraine being you know that
Ukrainian separatists who speak Russian
have a commonality with Russian and
they're all Russians he said I talked
about China and what an opportunity
there was for China because China has -
and Russia has natural resources so
there's a real opportunity for some an
economic connection between the two he
talked a lot about economics with in a
small speech he gave and then with
others the Greek Prime Minister spoke
and and a vice premier from China spoken
Xand and Vladimir Putin spoke and then
he and I did about a 40-minute interview
101 more politics and national security
issues than the neck anomic issues
although some economic issues and then
they went the whole thing the plenary
session went two and a half hours we
started a little after 2:00 and then it
went to little after 4:30 so it's a very
long I was on stage for the entire time
as was viral Putin
and you know it gave me an opportunity
to see him and up close and see how he
responds and what kind of I didn't look
into her eyes as George Bush once said
but I was able to get a sense of
watching his body movement income from
what seemed to intrigue for example I
pointed out that he was being very
aggressive Russia was and I said I know
you don't like to hear that and in his
answer he acknowledged he said no no I
don't like that he said I think we're
only doing what what we have to do but I
pointed out a number of things that they
were doing including things that the
United States object to greatly on the
border of in the eastern part of Ukraine
well Charlie I like what you said about
how you got to look at him look at his
body language you might not have stared
into his eyes the way President George W
Bush did but I wonder on which parts on
which topics which points was President
Laramie or Putin most unscripted on did
you where did you see the emotion come
out well I think what somebody motion it
got more emotional as we went and at the
end I mean the most emotional thing was
that that vague of my executive producer
because they had some foul-ups in
communications and she was with me for
for Charlie Rose and she was sitting in
the front row because we had to give
signals in order so that I could keep up
with where we were in the program and
that the end of it Putin said you know
you and I've been very busy and and
there a lot of other people are working
hard including your colleague who is
giving you the time signals and he asked
her to stand up and she did she was
sitting next to his
Dmitry Peskov who is one of his
principal advisors and the man who sort
of takes care of the door leading to
Vladimir Putin
he's he was very animated about Isis and
then and we're
how important it was to to change the
trajectory of Isis and we talked about
that and you know he doesn't miss an
opportunity ever to you know point out
if he thinks the United States is
responsible as he pointed out that the
rise of Isis came as a consequences of
what happened in Iraq he
he didn't like me talking about him
being aggressive as I may have mentioned
to you but he he someone said to me
after as a minister from Russia came
over to see me and he said you know we
what was really interesting for us and
they said he thought it was more relaxed
than he'd seen him in most occasions
like this but he said we know what he
thinks but we don't think many other
people know what he thinks and and here
was a chance for him to lay it out a lot
of people in Russia outside of Russia a
worry about Ukraine they're worried
about it because there is
point/counterpoint there will be an
announcement of sending maybe troops to
the Baltic States and reinforcing their
armaments and at the same time that will
be a counterpoint where Russia will talk
about our Putin will talk about you know
what we will do and we'll talk about new
ICBMs and things like that so you get a
sense it's very important to understand
people I think right and so questions do
have power even if even if they don't
answer the direct question or if in fact
they engage in their own spin it's
important to watch them and see them and
I think Putin believes that too that
three things that I've noticed about him
in reading and talking to people one
he's very very sensitive about borders
you know there's no idea that has made
them in Russians certainly Putin's a
more
alarm than it is the expansion of NATO
you know and that is the one thing that
I think they had to do with what
happened in
giorgia and how he reacts to NATO
he's worried about NATO expansion
because it's already expanded into the
Baltic States with all kinds of you know
geopolitical questions in terms of if
they if he pushed into one of those
Baltic states what would be the US
response will be NATO's response because
NATO they're all pledged to defend any
NATO country so they worry about kind of
miscalculation that might might take
place everybody's a word about that I
talked to a range of important American
officials and diplomats and journalists
as well to a person they said the thing
I'm most interested in is I want to know
step by step how he wants to reduce the
tension because he's part of that same
thing is true in Syria he has a
relationship that he has met a principal
benefactor of Syria and you know he
basically knows he's got a problem he
worries most about Isis taken over Syria
I think more so than he does about the
survival of Assad but he he said it's up
to the Syrian people
okay Charlie Rose we thank you so much
for giving us your your takeaway from
your conversation with President
Vladimir Putin this morning in st.
Petersburg